what makes you so good what uh what
What's the breakdown of the strengths
and weaknesses
so that's I think probably my biggest
strength is that I'm a universal player
I can play pretty much any opening
strategy doesn't doesn't really matter
um beyond that I think it's mainly that
I don't really make many blunders I
don't make blunders unless I'm under a
lot of pressure generally so that I mean
I know I'm I'm oversimplifying it's not
as as simple as does this apply to uh to
Blitz as well I think it's much more
applicable to Blitz in particular
because my intuition is very good so
when I'm making less blunders with
limited time on the clock my opponents
actually make a lot more blunders that
that's why I think it's much more
pronounced in Blitz than it is in
classical chess because in Blitz when
you're down to like 10 seconds uh in the
game both players have 10 seconds my
intuition is just better than theirs I
mean Magnus maybe not so clear but like
if you look at other players say Fabiano
caruana very strong player when he gets
down to 10 seconds or in these these uh
these situations he almost always makes
a blunder almost always um so I'm just
more precise I make less blunders and
that that's really the the effect is
much more dramatic but what do you think
that intuition is like uh sorry for the
kind of
uh like almost philosophical question
what what is that is that calculation
or is it some kind of weird memory
recall what is that like being able to
do that Short Line
prediction I think that's just playing
so many games online and there's some
kind of subconscious field that I have
because when you're that low on time you
can't calculate it's just you have to
look you just have to figure out what's
the move you want to play is no
calculation and just go with it and I
think just playing so many games
probably I mean I'm guessing I've played
over 300 000 games online and I think
just playing all those games it's it's a
feel there's there's no tangible way uh
that I can't put that really into words
it's just a feel what do you Visual and
we should say that you're I think
currently the number one ranked Blitz
player in the world you have uh been for
a while you're unquestionably one of the
greatest so the classical
rapid and Blitz you're one of the best
people for many years in the world okay
but you're currently number one in Blitz
um
so I I'd love to kind of for you to dig
into the secret to your success in Blitz
is it as you're saying that intuition
being able to when the time is short
to not make blunders and then to make a
close to Optimal move I think it's
generally that
I'm able to keep the games going no
matter what until we're low on time I'm
always able to do that yeah like if we
play a game with three minutes like
there are games I will just win win very
quickly but a lot of games between top
players players have to think you have
to use time and in those final critical
stages I just don't blunder I just don't
blunder really at the end of the day
that's that's really the only difference
because everybody's very very strong
but it's sort of like who is the who is
the better like brain who has a better
like CPU or for lack of a better way of
putting it it's like who makes a split
to SEC Split Second decisions the best
and uh I do think that I'm extremely
good at that in a way that almost nobody
else is that that really is the only
difference is that the Split Second
decisions because you can get a worse
position but again if you keep the game
going players have to use a time when
you get down to those final 10 15
seconds I almost always end up winning
in those situations what are you
visualizing like when it knows when
you're doing the fast fast calculations
what what is it um it's basically you
look at a move and you see like when
it's like five seconds or ten seconds
you play a movie you just make sure that
it's not a blunder you just look make
sure it's not a blender and you just go
with it and the first part though is the
feel so it's like I see this move and it
looks right I don't know why it's right
I can't put that into words but it looks
like the right move and then I look very
for like a split second see as long as
it's not some kind of blender and you
just play that move is there a bit of a
tunnel vision are you able to understand
the positions of all the other pieces on
the board or are you just focusing on a
very specific interaction it's just Phil
it's really just feel it's like this
move feels right and so I play it when
you when you're at that stage of the
game it's it's like as long as it's not
a blunder and it just that it's just
that feel there's there is no way for me
to put that in and that feel
like empirically does result in low
probability of blender for you yeah it's
like you don't blunder even though there
could be like you don't forget like a
random piece that was like very very I
mean it does happen of course but very
rarely and I mean I've done it on stream
many times like it's just you you go
with the move that for whatever reason
like it just intuitively whether it's
from playing hundreds of thousands of
games on the internet
um or just that that experience like it
you just intuitively can can feel like
the move is right